got to respect or would you get into any
sort of entrepreneurial situations where
you know maybe you know some isaiah shot
french fries or something or
bro if i could have um like something
like a waffle house out here
do you miss that about being in the
south like just i like the quality of
stuff in la mm-hmm i like the
convenience and the familiarity and
stuff in itself so i probably like
try to make something that's tasty a
little bit better than waffles but price
is about the same but like waffle house
is like
[ __ ] the type i used to be the type
that i would travel for that
for waffle house yeah yeah like i go
cross state lines for that wah is
amazing and it's very slept on and you
know what i like about waffle house is
when you're really shit-faced and you're
at a waffle house it's like three thirty
nine you see i feel you that's cool you
conversate with the people cooking your
food
because you're drunk but they're right
there they're making it to the future
my memory come from like going with my
grandma when i was like i didn't realize
you know when you don't realize you're
poor
and then you're going to do [ __ ] with
your grandparents and your parents and
like wipeouts were just fire then i grew
up and realized that's just like seven
dollars right i'm like that [ __ ] is
high memory quality for 70 bucks baby
yeah when i was a kid i used to think
applebee's was like the fanciest
restaurant in the world i mean you just
got bad taste and then no no no because
i was like the [ __ ] you see the
commercial you know my parents was
taking me to [ __ ] bees trash no i'm
not saying that i'm saying i just was
good i would think of applebee's and
chili's
it's like fried sticks i always would
think applebee's and chili's were like
expensive restaurants like man
i hope one day i get to go to applebee's
chili's when they still had
country fries steak i i take it as a
two and a half star applebee's for sure
two star but applebee's you get the two
for 20. that's why i mean
okay if it's fire i don't need it i
don't need a coupon
it's not a coupon it's just what they do
it's a it's basically
you ever